i'm maria bartiromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday july 13th 2022
i'm dave anthony
president biden is in the middle east on
a trip that'll take him to saudi arabia
we ought to get his tail back here you
got to come back to united states of
america and tell the political the
progressive left inside his own party
that our dream was a lie that with this
transition away from fossil fuels is
going to take time
i'm jessica rosenthal elon musk said no
deal and then posted a meme of himself
laughing about the twitter deal he was
ending on twitter attorneys for twitter
then said we'll see you in court it's
not yet clear who will have the last
laugh they're going to take it in the
court and
there'll be many experts many lawyers
you know many fees paid out to make the
both sides of the case and then at that
point the other judge will decide
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
president biden took a late night flight
starting a trip to the middle east this
trip will reinforce a vital american
role in a strategically consequential
region that's national security adviser
jake sullivan israel is the first stop
then the president will go to the west
bank and meet with the palestinian
president he'll also go to saudi arabia
president believes that the price of gas
is too high
and that we need to do more with respect
to global energy supplies and he will
take every step in his power both here
at home and in terms of his diplomatic
engagement in the world to try to bring
that about now president biden will not
be going to iran but that country will
certainly be part of the discussions
what they have said they're trying to do
is to build out a coalition
to push back against iran former
secretary of state mike pompeo is now a
fox news contributor but what they've
done has been just the opposite of that
they've allowed the iranian regime to
have wealth and resources and money the
iranians are now according to national
security adviser jack sullivan going to
provide drones for the russians to kill
more ukrainians they've pushed away our
friends our partners in kingdom of saudi
arabia calling them a pariah nation and
then it sounds like the president is
going to uh visit what what he would
call the west bank and go visit the
palestinians when he should be working
with the israeli government to push back
against iran to support the israelis to
make clear that jerusalem is the capital
right
something that they've pushed back
against saying we're going to put our
consulate in jerusalem as well a
consulate inside the country of israel
the words that they've used about what
they're hoping to accomplish on this
trip are deeply inconsistent with the
actions they have taken in their first
first 18 months in office are you
talking about iran the president in a
washington post op-ed wrote that after
my predecessor reneged on a nuclear deal
that was working
iran passed a law mandating the rapid
acceleration of the nuclear program
blaming
the acceleration on the u.s pulling out
of that deal and then he wrote the
united states found itself isolated and
alone by that decision what's your
response
it's counter factual faults
you picked the description i might just
always turn to facts iran has never been
more isolated i can prove it their
economy was failing and by
administration came in lifted the
sanctions that we'd had in place by
seeking to tell everyone we're not going
to enforce them that is wink and a nod
and the iranian economy will grow this
year this year the ukrainian economy
will grow faster than the american
economy and so if you're looking for the
path forward you need only ask the
israelis the emiratis the kuwaitis the
omanis the israelis frankly the american
people as well
we had isolated in iran they had never
been isolated before we had denied them
the wealth and resources to build out
their nuclear program as they have done
over these last 18 months where it has
accelerated this creates enormous risk
for the american people and for the
israelis our good friend and partner in
the region and that is dangerous
vladimir putin the russian leader he
will go to iran next week and he's going
to have meetings with not just iran's
leader but also the president of turkey
erdogan
turkey is a nato member what do you make
of this trip so it's
always been a complicated relationship i
hope that president erdogan is going
there to tell the russians and the
iranians that they need to change their
ways i doubt that that's going to be
successful for him we'll have to see
what comes from the meeting but make no
mistake about it if one looks to make
sure that we don't have to send our
young kids to fight and die in the
middle east something that for four
years we prevented from happening in the
trump administration if you want to keep
our kids from having to go solve
problems in the middle east the way to
do that
is to put pressure on the world's
largest state sponsor terry the iranian
regime to support the iranian people
today there are protesters protesting in
the streets of iran and the
administration hasn't even encouraged
them hasn't even supported them they'll
likely be
bludgeoned by the iranian leaders we
should support the iranian people oppose
the iranian theocracy and help our arab
state allies have the resources they
need to defend their own nations
president biden's plan to go to saudi
arabia is not without controversy he'll
meet with the king and the crown prince
mohammed bin salman who the cia
concluded ordered the 2018 murder of
washington post columnist jamal
khashoggi
during a presidential debate on msnbc
november 20th 2019 then candidate joe
biden said he would punish the saudis i
would make it very clear we were not
going to in fact sell more weapons to
them we were going to in fact make them
pay the price and make them in fact the
pariah that they are in 2018 secretary
of state pompeo called the murder
heinous but urged the senate not to
condemn the crown prince saying it would
upend a plan to stop the saudi conflict
with rebels in yemen passing a
resolution this point undermines that it
would encourage the houthis it would
encourage the iranians it would it would
undermine the fragile
agreement the senate ultimately did pass
that resolution condemning the crown
prince
the kingdom of saudi arabia has been an
important security partner for the
united states of america for an awfully
long time and if you go actually read
what the cia said it's a bit different
than you described it okay but be that
but be that as it may the importance of
the kingdom of saudi arabia is evidenced
by the fact that joe biden is headed
there this week the president biden is
headed there this week he sees that he
made a mistake when he campaigned by
saying we're going to make them a pariah
state the threat to the people of
america we put america first for four
years the threat the united states of
america doesn't come from the kingdom of
saudi arabia or from the emirates or
from kuwait or oman the threat to the
united states of america comes from the
iranian regime and we should be resolved
and focused and be working with our
partners in the region to push back to
protect the american people from that
very threat okay what about the human
rights issues what about something the
issue like with khashoggi like with the
crown prince
there there's still a lot of emphasis on
him and
what happens with human rights in saudi
arabia how do you have them as a partner
and still deal with that issue at the
same time like president biden says he's
going to do
oh this is not difficult at all
america's interests and our commitment
to human rights is consistent
we're the we're the greatest most
fundamentally decent nation in the world
but we end up meeting with chairman kim
i met with vladimir putin i met with a
taliban we we deal with lots of actors
in the world who are difficult and andre
and don't share our value sets we're
working to deliver good outcomes for the
american people we should never lose
sight of that if you're looking for who
the bad actor is in the middle east the
iranians have killed far more people
than the saudis ever could have even be
accused of right this is not a close
call and president biden talks about the
middle east and fails to even so much as
mentioned afghanistan where we left
americans behind
we always press for every nation to be
better and in fact the kingdom of saudi
arabia is getting better under the
leadership of this king and now this
crown prince the human rights situation
in the kingdom of saudi arabia is far
better for the average woman in saudi
arabia today than it was two years ago
four years ago or ten years ago it may
not be happening fast enough
we may wish that it were
even better but i don't think there
anyone can look at the saudi arabia of
today and deny that the human rights
situation in saudi arabia is better
today for the average saudi citizen than
it was before the crown prince had
become the crown prince of course
president biden is going to be
discussing with the saudis and others in
that region the issue of oil
we have seen the price of oil and
gasoline come down in the last month or
so but
it's still an issue with the ongoing war
in ukraine with russia and the sanctions
what do you think the president should
say
we know what the real cause of this
problem is it is not the kingdom of
saudi arabia it is not vladimir putin it
is president by brethren made a clear
decision he talked in the campaign
about saying we're not going to do
fossil fuels in the united states and
we're not going to drill we're not going
to frack he said we're not going to do
it when you tell and we told banks don't
invest in these things don't help
finance these transactions that allow us
to produce our own energy for four years
america was energy dominant we had
affordable energy so people could drive
their cars so people could afford the
electricity to cool their homes in the
summer and heat their homes in the
winter food wasn't as expensive because
energy is a huge component of food costs
as well this president has chosen the
green climate
mantra he has chosen greta thunder over
the american people and when you do that
the american people are going to suffer
and so you know i hope he'll be able to
convince opec and the kingdom of saudi
arabia to produce some more energy but
the answer to providing affordable
energy for the american people is right
here at home and he gotta get his tail
back here you gotta come back the united
states of america and tell the political
the progressive left inside his own
party that our dream
was a lie
that with this transition away from
fossil fuels is going to take time and
that america is going to produce the
energy it needs on an affordable basis
today to protect the american way of
life but
the price of gas did go up more than a
dollar after the invasion of ukraine
russia is still in the middle of that
war
we've put sanctions on them
do you agree with the sanctions we've
put on russia should we be doing more
oh no
we've gotten it completely wrong the
ruble's still very very high
we've failed to impose sanctions on them
that actually can impact what we all
want we all want this war to end we are
looking for a way to make this conflict
vanish to save the ukrainian people's
lives to protect europe and to protect
the american people as well we've put
sanctions on that are half measures the
ruble is as high today as it was when
the war started back in february we we
know that people in moscow aren't
suffering right they've not been
impacted but it just tells you that
these sanctions haven't haven't been
successful at putting pressure on
vladimir putin we should have been more
serious we should have provided more
weapon systems to the ukrainians so they
could defend themselves had we done
those things we would have increased the
likelihood
that vladimir putin's perception of risk
as it was for four years when i was the
ci director of secretary of state for
four years he did not invade ukraine
he took crimea during the obama
administration he's now invaded ukraine
under the administration but for four
years he didn't do this i think it's
because he understood that we were
serious about protecting america all
right you mentioned secretary of state
cia director i have to ask you also of
course a member of congress from kansas
not a bad presidential resume is that a
job that you want are you seriously
considering a run i'm very focused on
making sure that the conservative ideas
that i've been working on for decades
get pushed forward the next chance to do
that is in november just a handful of
months away so i'm out helping others
campaign at the end of the year susan
and i will pray and think and make a
decision about how best we can do a good
turn for a country that's been so good
to both of us and
who knows what that will bring
i've spent time in iowa and new
hampshire
doing the things that one might do we'll
we'll make that decision come first of
the year all right one follow-up i have
to ask if donald trump is a candidate
would you run
we won't be impacted by who else chooses
to get in or or chooses not to get in in
that
very important very faithful decision
that uh every individual has to make for
themselves well fair enough and i i
appreciate you
answering both those questions thank you
very much
former secretary of state current fox
news contributor mike pompeo good to
talk to you thank you so much thank you
sir have a good day
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
he's the founder of tesla and spacex and
he was on track to own twitter according
to an agreement reached in late april
tesla ceo elon musk will buy twitter for
54.20 a share
or 44 billion dollars in a deal that
will take the popular micro blogging
service private but last week musk
announced the deal was off and in a
letter from his attorney said twitter is
in material breach of multiple
provisions of that april agreement and
said the company appears to have made
false and misleading representations the
letter cites a lack of information over
bots insisting that musk had spent two
months trying to get the data to make an
independent assessment of the prevalence
of fake or spam accounts twitter wrote
in their own letter that they have
breached nothing and tuesday the company
formally sued musk the fact that he
ripped a band-aid off friday night was a
shocker to the street i think it was a
shock to twitter and now they sharpen
their knives going to the delaware court
wedbush securities analyst dan ives told
fox business the worst thing that
happens to musk is that a court orders
him to follow through with the purchase
if you look up the term awkward that
would probably be uh the definition of
what happens there and
i think at that point it's probably
likely some sort of settlement
if that ultimately ended up because look
for twitter the last thing you want is
someone owning your company that didn't
want to own in the first place musk had
threatened to walk before this if the
company couldn't show that less than
five percent of its daily active users
were automated spam accounts last week
twitter said in a call to executives
that they remove one million spam
accounts a day and that spam accounts
represent well below five percent of its
active user base each quarter in the
lawsuit twitter says musk believes he is
free to change his mind trash the
company disrupt its operations destroy
stockholder value and walk away the
company requests an expedited trial for
the case to be heard in september this
is going to go on the court and
in the courtroom decision
you know the court could
force mr musk to buy at the 44 billion
dollar
number you know to engage in satisfying
performance
criteria david larker is a professor and
director of the corporate governance
research initiative at the stanford
graduate school of business you know
they could say you could walk away and
you may you know depending on how they
view it it could be for zero money or a
billion dollars or maybe more than that
or
you know there's always a possibility
for renegotiating this thing um yeah
that's all then though if you
renegotiate couldn't shareholders say
hey
you agreed to buy this for 54 you know
54 dollars and 20 cents a share could
could shareholders sue if if twitter
agrees to a lower price
well in the us
given our our legal system there will be
many many lawsuits filed on this but
you're right i mean
if you put yourself in the position of
the board of twitter i mean i think they
did a really nice job they did exactly
what they were supposed to do they got
an unsolicited offer
formed a special committee and the
independent directors got outside legal
and in finance council they thought
about it and said you know 5420 seems
seems okay we'll do it
contracts were written both sides signed
it and then you know financing was
arranged and at that point you know the
deal typically progresses with you know
various due diligence and other kinds of
things so
it's hard for a board um let's say a
deal came back at i'm i'm making this up
45 a share
you know is that an acceptable deal can
the boards you know look at that and say
yeah we agreed at 54-20 we thought that
was a good deal but
for whatever reasons there might be
we're willing to take it for 45 but i
mean
it puts the board in a really tough
position and so i think the board looked
at this and said you know 54-20 seems
pretty good for a price per share
and now
we might be able to get a billion dollar
breakup fee
and you know what's the chance is that
that we could get a favorable ruling
were to get more than a billion dollars
and so they're going to take it in the
court and
there'll be many experts many lawyers
you know many fees paid out to make the
both sides of the case and then at that
point the other judge will decide
yeah let me ask you because um you know
musk said that twitter was in material
breach of multiple provisions as we've
all read that letter
and that they may have made false and
misleading representations we know
as he has said and his attorney said in
that letter that the issue is fake or
spam accounts musk's attorneys say
he wanted to do an independent
assessment of such accounts and that by
twitter's own admission they didn't
provide enough data for such an
assessment and they referenced a letter
written to this effect on june 29th
twitter attorneys say the company will
continue to provide information
reasonably requested by musk under the
agreement
does this then come down to what was
specifically stated
in the original agreement from april
25th in other words if musk wanted all
of this information about bots or spam
accounts then what was agreed to on
april 25th is the issue
well that's exactly right i mean so it's
going to turn on contract law and merger
and acquisition law and you know i i
haven't read the
contracts in grizzly detail but yeah
there'll be specific things in there
that you know if you don't do this then
you're in breach and a variety of
remedies will take place or things like
that but
yeah i mean it's all going to turn on
i'd say expert opinion
and legal opinion with regard to
what was in the contract what's
considered a breach did twitter give
information in a timely manner you know
what were the truthful representations
and then i mean who knows i mean you
know the data analysts
uh hired by mr musk will look at this
and say you know we think it's way more
than five percent and you know there was
issues here that weren't appropriately
disclosed by twitter now i'm sure
twitter has analyzed this stuff in some
detail and um so it'd be a little bit of
a battle between experts is what was the
number
and once the number is maybe agreed to
then the legal system will come along
and say is that is that material so i
mean there's a lot of unknowns here but
yeah i mean i think we understand the
steps we're going to go through and and
the analysis that's going to be brought
into court
and that'll all be pulled together and
the judge or the chancellor whoever's
going to do this you know will make a
reasoned decision but
the size of the deal is something i
don't think the delaware courts have
looked at so i mean this is going to be
a very very important decision it will
set the precedent going forward
yeah i have to ask you about that meme
musk himself tweeted i'm sure you've
seen it i think everybody's seen it i
think it has over a million likes at
this point it's of him laughing
harder and harder as the commentary goes
on it says
they said i couldn't buy twitter then
they wouldn't disclose bot info now they
want to force me to buy twitter in court
now they will have to disclose bot info
in court
i don't
know legally how this will how this will
work if that issue will be forced but
it does sound like what you're saying is
okay if you want to get into this over
what's a material breach
then
we will have to have this discussion
about whether or not twitter was
supposed to
um turn over that kind of information
yeah and whether they did turn it over
in a timely manner was it the
information that was needed
so
this is where you're going to have first
class data analysis
people on both sides saying you know
here's what we think the number is
but even after that sort of settle or
you know the sides have their own
numbers i mean let's say the number was
15 would the court view that as a
material breach i i really don't know
but i mean that's the path
right we're going down
you know the tweet about
um they said we couldn't buy twitter and
all that kind of stuff i don't i don't
think it does you a lot of good i think
you get a lot of sympathy in court for
those kind of statements
as somebody who studies corporations and
these sorts of matters were you
surprised when you heard that elon musk
waived due diligence on this deal
so that was what was reported i mean i
think you'd really have to know whether
that was literally true and
i suspect that it's not
quite as straightforward as that um you
know that'd be a very cavalier thing to
do and again it's going to turn on
the legal definitions in here i mean
yeah there were obviously
parts of the transaction
where he had to line up the finance if
he couldn't line up the financing you
know they would have a break um but
apparently the financing was lined up
and there were you know contracts to to
make it happen
i find it hard to believe that there's a
complete waiver of due diligence but
again i wasn't in the room and so i
don't really know
yeah there's another sort of unconfirmed
thing that's floating out there that
twitter gave musk a fire hose so that he
could analyze each tweet in real time
again
not confirmed by either side
but
it does sort of beg the question right
and you've kind of referenced this
earlier just as somebody who pays
attention to what corporations should do
and have
do you believe twitter probably does
have
this information i mean they've admitted
that they remove a million spam accounts
a day in your mind is it probably likely
that they have the information musk is
looking for like how many
spam or bot or fake accounts are there
no i mean they clearly do some sort of
analysis like that i mean their
advertisers would require them you know
to remove what appears to be fake hits i
mean because you know
that would have an impact on the the
cost of advertising on twitter but
the debate is going to be how you define
these things and
what does a bot really look like you
know and
you pointed out the fire hose of data i
mean that's just the nature of this
there's you know
many many transactions and
and but you know think about the the
flip side of this let's say you didn't
provide the fire hose of information and
you provided selected pieces of it then
the comeback would be well you're hiding
something you only gave us
part that you wanted to give us where
you know here's the whole thing in some
structured format
so i mean it's huge data there's ways to
sample it and things like that but i
mean
part of it's going to turn on i think
you know what is the bot how many were
there yeah did twitter you know have
misleading disclosure things like that
that'll be a key part of this
so twitter sued in the chancery court in
delaware the new york times says this is
a court of equity rather than law as it
allows for more flexible resolutions
than the law formally provides
they've dealt with business issues
before and acquisitions
even forcing tyson to get over what it
called buyer's regret when it tried to
back out of taking over a meat
distributor nearly two decades ago right
yeah i mean i think that the delaware
workforce do try to
find something that seems equitable
and they've done this
a lot it's just
this one is just so big and the players
are so visible um
it's going to be a tough one i mean you
don't want
to come across
as
looking like you've been bullied by one
side or the other and you know it's a
fair representation and
you know what's equitable so
you know the outcome as we talked about
earlier it can be many things but it's
just it's worth watching and
it'll be fascinating
professor david larker thank you so much
for your time
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
and in other news i'm gianna delosi ask
any dog owner about their beloved pooch
and you're bound to get a personality
breakdown likened to that of a dating
app biography he loves to play fetch but
hates the water shy but quirky when he
gets to know you some pets even are
chosen based on their breed stereotypes
like golden retriever being a good
family dog or a german shepherd as a
good guard dog but a recent study
published in the journal science shows
breed has less to do with personality
than we may have once thought
researchers set up a website called
darwin's arc which collected survey and
genetic data from dogs across the u.s
since 2015. pet parents answer more than
100 questions and they swab their dog's
cheek for some dna sequencing thousands
of dogs were surveyed and sequenced it
was the largest study of its kind the
result at least 80 percent of appearance
can be tied to dna like a dalmatian
spots or a border collie's curled tail
but personality is a whole different
ball field
behaviors like a retriever retrieving
are likely inherited but less than one
quarter of personality differences could
be explained by the genetics like how
friendly a dog is or how playful a dog
is researchers also did not find a
genetic basis for aggressive behaviors a
point that's long been argued by pit
bull owners the bottom line
man's best friend they're just like us
for the fox news rundown i'm gianna
delosi
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind as a former leftist
i can tell you that the best way to
gauge the woke strategy of the left is
to watch what's happening in san
francisco and london
in both cities there is little pushback
by opponents and they tend to serve as
petri dishes for the left's cancerous
agenda so when the left's agenda begins
to fail in the supposedly liberal
utopias it's our first sign that the
tide is turning against the fear mongers
sensors bullies and workstars
san franciscans sent the world a message
when they recalled three progressive
school board members and their far left
district attorney however the nefarious
agenda of the left isn't reserved just
for the united states and much like here
there are signs that the people of
england have had enough of the left's
absurd social justice nonsense in this
glorious example of how the rejection of
the woke left is becoming universal
england is now stepping up with a new
law mandating that new buildings housing
offices must include single-sex
bathrooms for a country that has been
putting up with forced sharing of
bathrooms euphemistically called gender
neutral facilities the british have had
enough the new york post reported a
british government source told the
telegraph quote it is vital that women
feel safe and comfortable when using
public facilities and that there is a
greater emphasis on provision that is
focused on dignity privacy tolerance and
respect for all
the paper reported that ministers are
likely to present the new policies as a
common sense way to impede the recent
trend in which gender neutral bathrooms
have become standard in newly
constructed buildings
common sense indeed but england isn't
done in what is being called the biggest
pr blunder in british banking history
the social media team for the british
banking brand halifax thought it was a
good idea to announce on twitter that
its employees would have their pronouns
listed on their name badges they
explained this was necessary to keep
people from accidentally misgendering
their staff
let's just say that their customers
reaction on social media was swift and
not complimentary further proving that
enough is enough everywhere on the
wokism front the daily mail reports the
row began when halifax tweeted it's a
hundred and eighteen thousand followers
revealing that it would allow staff to
display their pronouns on their name
badges in a post that read pronouns
matter
after being roasted on social media by
furious customers a tweet from halifax
appeared just 20 minutes later smugly
stating quote
we strive for inclusion equality and
quite simply doing what's right if you
disagree with our values you're welcome
to close your account
signed by an andy m
halifax should be taking a hint at what
netflix understands about alienating
your customer base it's not exactly the
best business practice as fast as you
can say canceled it became clear people
were taking andy up on his suggestion
and it appears it's not just a gaggle of
20-something social justice activists
undermining the bank via its social
media account on their website they
actually threatened to close the
accounts of people they deem transphobic
and even threaten to turn those people
into the police
the thought police are ready to turn you
in for wrong speak it's madness yes and
a perfect example of the destruction the
left would bring to every business it
infects no matter the country city or
industry it also highlights the antidote
of customers and citizens speaking up
rejecting and condemning it let's hope
the people from san francisco to london
continue to show everyone the way out of
the leftist abyss
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 pm
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest news makers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes